Muslims are buying and transforming
American churches into mosques, and
Americans are angry about it. But is
their anger being directed at the right
source? We shall see. Our story begins
with a year old video clip that only
recently went viral on X. In it, one
Muhammad Musi, maybe Mustri, Egyptian,
president of an organization called
American Islam and chairman of the board
of the Islamic Society of Central
Florida, appears saying during a Friday
sermon that due to its quote
unimpressive dogma of someone being
crucified, Christianity is dying out in
America preparing the way for Islam. his
exact
words. Quote, "A lot of Christians are
leaving their faith, especially the
young generation. The churches are
emptying out. The Pew Research Center
has shown that in the last 10 years, 28%
of people have left the church and
become atheists or agnostics. They are
not impressed anymore by the dogma that
someone 2,000 years ago was crucified
for their sins. They are searching for
something that is more meaningful, that
is consistent with science, and
consistent with the principles that we
know today. Islam is the answer for them
and we are jumping on the opportunities.
As such, Muslims are busy buying up and
transforming churches into mosques as
part of their Islamization of America
program. In the words of Sheh Muhammad,
he continues, quote, "As these churches
empty out, we are buying these
churches. We bought three churches so
far and converted them into mosques in
Florida. And now we have one we are
buying with a school. The people he
means the non-Muslim Americans who are
part of that community one day will be
Muslims. So we will make it into a
mosque and an Islamic school for our
children and their children inshallah.
Allah willing. I ask Allah to give Islam
victory in this
country. Shocked are you? Well, you
shouldn't be. There's really nothing new
or surprising about such words and
goals. Indeed, around the very same time
that Sheikh Muhammad was boasting about
purchasing churches in Florida, Muslims
had purchased another large, especially
important and historic Catholic church
in New York. St. An's Church, Buffalo,
New York, permanently closed, Father
Ronald Verling wrote in a post on August
11th, 2024. Sold to the Islamic
community for $250,000 who are
converting the historic church into a
mosque.
In both cases, that of the Florida
churches and that of this historic New
York church, social media users
expressed outrage. Thus, to quote from
the most popular comment concerning
Shikh Muhammad's supplication to Allah
to transform even more churches into
mosques, one user named Mag 1775
wrote, quote, "That's not a prayer,
that's a threat." He's referring to
Muhammad's uh supplication to Allah that
more more churches become
mosques. Uh he continues, "Converting
churches, claiming territory, preaching
takeover sounds less like faith, more
like infiltration. This is America, not
a caliphate. We don't kneel to Sharia
and Florida damn sure won't fall without
a fight. We stand for Christ's
constitution and country." No retreat,
no surrender. Similar outrage was voiced
regarding the New York church to the
point that the aforementioned Father
Verling had to issue a follow-up
statement saying quote no anger should
be directed against the Islamic
community. The parish complex was made
available for sale by the dascese. This
scenario is being played out in one
large urban dascese across the country.
So what to make of all this? For
starters, let no one be deceived. For
Muslims, these purchases are not mere
business transactions. A point is being
made. From its very origins, Islam
always sought to convert the temples of
other religions into mosques. Victory
mosques to be precise. Past and present.
One of the very first signs of Muslim
consolidation was and is the erection of
a mosque at top the sacred sites of the
vanquished. The pagan Cabba temple in
Arabia was converted into Islam's
holiest site, the mosque of Mecca. The
Al Axa mosque, Islam's third holiest
site, was built at top Solomon's temple
in Jerusalem. The omi mosque was built
at top the church of St. John the
Baptist and the Haga Sophia was
converted into a mosque upon the
conquest of Constantinople in 1453 and
again recently for Muslims the
transformation of non-Muslim places of
worship into mosques is the physical
manifestation and validation of Islam's
ancient battle cry Allah Akbar which
simply means my God is greater than your
God as seen by Allah taking up residence
in the temple of his vanquished
counterparts the transformation of
Christian churches into mosques is
especially emblematic of this phenomenon
because most of the land Islam conquered
or stole from Morocco in the west to
Iraq in the east was for centuries
Christian. Most of the religious houses
that were turned into victory mosques
were churches. As such, the
transformation of American churches into
mosques is for Muslims another example
of Islam's triumph over its Christian
nemesis. Allah Akbar will be chanted as
the Muslim deity makes his residence in
the many vacated churches of Florida,
New York, and all across America. Even
so, when Father Verling wrote that
quote, "No anger should be directed as
against the Islamic community, that also
is true. Muslims are after all only
doing what is good for them and their
religion. Who can blame them? They are
not directly conquering anyone or
enexing any building. Every American
church they transform into a mosque was
sold to them, often for a few silver
pieces." This is the point that so many
Western folk who are otherwise wise to
Islam and its ws do not seem to
understand. Muslims cannot be faulted
for flooding Western Europe or for
having so many children so that the
number one name for newborn baby boys in
several Western capitals is Muhammad or
for advocating for laws and behavior
that conform to Sharia. In doing all of
these things, they are merely engaging
in self-preserving and self-promoting
activities which is how all normal
people behave. So how can they be blamed
for buying and turning churches into
mosques when those churches are offered
to them? Alarmed Christians or Americans
in general will get nowhere until they
learn to point their fingers in the
right direction at themselves or at
least at their elected leaders who
empower Muslims over Americans and then
do something about it. An example of how
American leaders help empower Islam in
America just occurred a few days ago on
May 2nd. New York City Mayor Eric Adams
decreed that mosques no longer need to
apply for permits to blast their call to
prayers on loudspeakers.
Do you think American leaders would ever
allow American churches to blast
Christian calls to speakers, thereby
annoying surrounding non-Christians the
way non-Muslims are now going to be
annoyed, not to mention overwhelmed with
Islamic propaganda all throughout New
York City? In short, yes, Christians
should be angered that their churches
are being pawned off to Muslims who turn
them into mosques. But Christian anger,
if it is ever to be of any value, should
be less directed against Muslims, whose
actions are normal and representative of
a people seeking to preserve and promote
itself, and more towards themselves and
their leaders, whose actions are
suicidal, and precisely what has led to
so much Muslim empowerment in the West.